[Music]
thanks for joining us what if you didn't
have any payments what if there was no
master card you hadn't discovered
bondage or American distress you weren't
caught in a car fleece you gave Sallie
Mae her eviction notice and kicked the
old woman out into the street think
about your budget right now think about
your income what if you had no car
payment no credit card payments no
student loan payment no medical bills
outstanding what if you had no debt what
if you had no mortgage payment all you
had to buy was lights water and food
some insurance and you could do some
investing how much would you give if you
weren't broke if you weren't working for
everybody else if you weren't working
for Lexus Motor Credit Toyota Motor
Credit Chrysler Motor Credit Ford Motor
Credit how many Motor credits do I have
to give you before you get this if you
weren't working for countrywide if you
weren't working for Visa and MasterCard
and God help you Bank of America if you
weren't working for Sallie Mae what if
you worked for you well if you had no
payments would you work at the job you
work at if you didn't have to to pay
payments would you take a different job
would you tell them to take that job and
yeah you would wouldn't you next time
the boss comes in being a jerk you could
just start walking out
where you going I don't have any
payments you see proverbs 22:7 and the
Bible says the borrower is slave to the
lender now Dave Ramsey you're one of
those crazy Christian people aren't you
yep unabashedly so darling but that's
not really crazy it's just kind of
common sense
the borrower's slave to the lender you
tell me are you a slave or not slaves
don't have choices other people tell
them what to do their life is owned by
someone else I owe I owe so off to work
I go says the bumper-sticker ha ha not
funny
spend your whole life giving money to
people who have 50 storey buildings in
the skyline guess who paid for those you
the borrower is slave to the lender have
you ever thought that there might it
might not be possible to be generous
when you're a slave when someone else
controls you how hard is it to be
generous what if you had no payments
could you build wealth the average car
payment in America is 504 dollars right
now over 84 months if you invest 504
dollars in a decent growth stock mutual
fund that has the rates of returns that
my personal mutual funds have had in my
personal 401k for the past 40 years if
you were to do that from age 30 to age
70 you'd have about 5.6 million dollars
in your Roth IRA just the car payment
that's what your car payments costing
you 5.6 million dollars hope you like
the car and they go down in value like a
rock that's where Chevy gets that like a
rock what it'd be like to have no
payments would you work where you work
if you didn't have to make money to pay
other people that you owe the number of
people who change careers or change jobs
once they're free and make the most
money they've ever made in their lives
because they're able to change jobs and
make the most money they've ever made in
their lives after they get out of debt
it's almost a common occurrence among
the debt-free screamers that while
they're getting out of debt or post debt
freedom they make different career
choices because they no longer feel
trapped you know why you feel trapped
when you got a bunch of payments because
you're trapped that's why you feel
trapped the borrower is slave to the
lender the only difference was this was
voluntary slavery you signed up for it I
signed up for it we were told that this
is how you live the little man can't get
ahead it takes money to make money
you're never gonna have anything nice so
you might as well have some decent
payments get low payments cuz you gets
only a little man like people are in our
neighborhood people like us people of
our ethnic background the only way we
get ahead is payments ever heard those
things heard of my whole life I've heard
them from every ethnic background by the
way I've heard them from Hispanics I've
heard them from African Americans I've
heard them from hillbillies and heard
them from Cajuns rednecks Yankees
Dutchman I've heard it from every German
background although most Germans are
pretty conservative financially I've
even heard it from Canadians go figure
you're not different
stupid knows no bounds stupid will show
up in any race in any region and it'll
settle in and make itself normal the
borrower is slave to the lender if you
didn't have any payments you could build
wealth couldn't you how fast would you
be a millionaire if you didn't have any
payments put your house payment in the
calculator as an investment instead of a
payment how fast would that turn into a
million dollars I'll help you with that
a
years eight years after you pay off your
house that one account will approximate
a million dollars of the average house
payment America today
this is ridiculous people everybody else
is getting rich and you're helping them
you're working and working and working
and working and working like a rat in a
wheel and you put yourself in the wheel
I did too
I've done so many stupid things with
money I can't even count them I have a
PhD in to UM be what qualifies you to do
this show Dave what degrees do you have
I've got something honey that you don't
have it's called experience been there
done that got all the t-shirts I got
every Boy Scout badge of stupidity that
there is I know exactly what stupid
looks like I've done it up close and
personal and called it smart you ever
done stupid and called it smart but when
stupid get stressed tested it gets
exposed to stupid doesn't it I mean when
the tide goes out you can tell he was
skinny-dipping can't you your great
little plan to invest in real estate
worked real good until 2008 didn't it
stupid your great little plan to do XYZ
worked until it didn't work didn't it
stupid your great little plan to go
$250,000 in debt to get a degree in
left-handed puppetry worked until it
didn't work didn't it stupid hey we've
all done stupid darlin the borrower is
slave to the lender voluntarily signing
up to give our lives away well this
shows about breaking free this shows
about no more chains this show is about
you taking back control of your destiny
this show is about believing and showing
you exactly how step by step process by
process you can get your most powerful
wealth building tool back it's called
your income and if you don't go get it
back it's going to be your fault because
I'm going to show you how if you don't
go get your income back it's gonna be
your fault because I'm going to inspire
you and show you other people that did
it if you don't go get control of your
life again by getting out of debt and
using your income to
bill wealth it's your fault starting
today I don't know how long you've been
listening to this show but it's time to
listen to what is being said on this
show you spent too much your life giving
it away to other people it's time aren't
you sick and tired of being sick and
tired it's time to do something about it
I've had it when you say that that's
when you change the borrower is slave to
the lender how much would you give if
you weren't in debt how much could you
invest if you weren't getting debt how
fast would you build wealth if you
weren't in debt this is the Dave Ramsey
show
[Music]